question is from an engineer by
profession and he would like to know uh
whether it's
permissible or can he says can I marry
in
Ramadan as far as marrying in the month
of Ramadan is concerned there's no text
in the Quran or any say had which I know
where is forbidden to marry in the month
of Raman a person can marry in any month
of the year but since in Ramadan he has
to abstain beside abstaining from food
and drink he has to abstain from sexual
intercourse so it depends upon him that
when he marries in the month of Ramadan
the lady he marries is a new wife so
will he be able to suppress his feeling
during the day time from the beginning
of dawn to Sunset that will be able to
abstain that is a test if he can abstain
from any sexual intercourse then he can
marry but since a person marries is in
the month of Ramadan it's a new wife he
has to spend time so therefore if he has
doubts it's advisable that he delays his
marriage after the month of Ramadan and
he spends time in the zikar and
remembrance of Allah subhana tala but
per marrying in the month of Ramadan is
not Haram